hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the 2019 FIBA World
Cup it's round three
Irish angry shoe versus Alexander grief
shock and congratulations to everyone
who figured out that the cold above the
board is actually by Bobby Fischer not
by Michael tall so there you have it now
it's all nice and fixed so without
further ado I thought this was the most
exciting game of round three so so let's
just check it out I know it's it's
pretty late later than usual then I
upload but I will I was busy you know
before so without further ado who opens
with d4 sorry about that with Knight to
f6 buggery shook
c4 e6 and Knight to c3 and here we don't
transpose into the Queen's again be the
client first we go into the nimzo-indian
defense with Bishop to b4 Knight to f3
and now d5 transposing into the ragas in
defense we have Queen to a4 with check
knife to c6 blocking to defend the
bishop on b4 III and we have castles by
Gary shook with Queen back the C - now
that the knight is no longer pinned and
b6 preparing defiantly to the light
square bishop and Bishop to d2 with
blush of the b7 and there is a game that
reached this position where C capture
sandy if I was played but shoe plays a
three here and now it is already as of
move eight that we have a completely new
game show of course not eager to give up
his bishop pair he goes rushing back to
d6 and now we have once we trade in the
center C captures he captures ended
Bishop to d3 now putting pressure on h7
for the moment it's not a target with a
six taking away the be five square from
White's pieces and now Knights t2 with
Knight to e7 preparing to bring this
night over to f5 at some point with
Bishop to c3 and now comes Knight e4
first
attacking the bishop on c3 here white
trades a bunch of capture sunny for the
captures on e4 and now Knight to g5
going after the d4 pawn here and the
Grisha continues with his plan
knife finally comes to f5 sorry not f5
Knight comes to d5 now I'm seems to be
what we should prefer the going after
the season Reed Bishop and here Knight
captures on e4 so shoe grabs a pawn but
it's not it's not really a great pawn
for example it opens up into the
diagonal of Ganesha light square bishop
and also allows Queen to h4 and Queen to
h4 is a very annoying move you have to
constantly keep an eye on a lot of
things for example you can't Castle
kingside because you're getting
checkmated to the bishop also attacks h2
for example if you Castle queenside you
get Knight captures on e3 and you open
up a double attack here against the
night also the Queen and c2 is under
attack you have to capture it and
Alberto captures on e4 black just has a
beautiful position here so we have
Knight back to g3 and here Knight
captures on c3 so Grisha eliminated both
of the bishops and now he has a bishop
pair against a knight pair with Knight
captures on c3 and now winning back his
pawn Bishop captures on g2 we have rook
to G 1 and now Bishop to f3 and it's
really it's just insane how a Gris shook
allowed this G file to become semi open
but on the other hand he's not allowing
the White King to go anywhere so Knights
the f5 here and this is just a beautiful
idea
the queen is under attack the bishop is
under attack the g7 point is under
attack so Hardy what do you play here
well Grisha allows the capture on g7
it's not like you can defend it with
Queen captures on h2 and now rook
captures on g7 of course this comes with
check we have team to h8 and now Knight
to e4 preparing this knight to come to
f6 so you can have some wealth pressure
on h7 and now bush up to h5 a very
important move you have to play Bishop
to g6 the refer to protect the h7 pawn
Knight to f6 by shoe and the now comes
Bishop to g6 and here why to decide at
the Castle queenside and it's a really
crazy position here I use this for the
thumbnail it's just just awesome
this room being placed on g7 but
castling queenside here doesn't really
work and the good issue he had he had a
winning move here so feel free to pause
the video and try to find this winning
idea for gorilla well I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent player and for
those of you if you just want to enjoy
the show
just Queen to h3 seems to be enough here
as there's a double attack on the night
here you can't really defend it because
if you defend it let's say you play
efore you just get Bishop captures and
you remove the defender of the rope here
so if you capture the bishop you lose
the rook on g7 and if you go rogue DG
one I just you know bring more rooks
into the game then you get Queen h6
check which will pick up the night here
and after King to be one Alexa King be
one you're gonna capture on f6 and after
each chapters on a5 you can even play
Queen captures here and now you have two
rooks and the bishop against the Queen
it's completely winning the game for
black but Grisha decided to go Bishop to
e7 first he put pressure on this night
here he was probably expecting Knight
captures Knight character Sonny 7 if
Knight captures only 7 then okay you've
eliminated the bishop but you lose the
Queen and c2 so there's that however he
missed one very important move from
white because it's now actually white
who has a winning position so once again
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea for white in this
position again while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
sacrificer of rooks and for those who
just want to enjoy the show
rook captures on h7 with check this is a
crazy line and I don't think anyone can
be blamed for missing this because it's
just it's just a wonderful line Bishop
captures on h7 of course Knight captures
on h7 and now Queen captures on h7 and
now you don't go after the bishop then
you can trade Queens and you don't have
all that much but what you can do and
what well obviously both of them is
Queen to e4 this is the move you have to
find if you find rook captures on h7
because now the threat of winning the
piece remains however the real threat is
rook to h1 and this just wins the Queen
and the game and there's nothing to do
you have to play Bishop d6
and after Luke to h1 block with Bishop -
- but it doesn't help
I just win - G - and now if Queen
captures on f5 rook captures an H - it's
game over
and if look to G H now I just play Queen
captures on H - a white is up a piece
and of course in a completely winning
position there's nothing to do here
if you capture the Queen then it's just
mate as the night covers the g7 square
so really just an insane insane idea
this rook captures on h7 but it only
works if you find Queen to e4 followed
by rook to h1 however who did not find
this he played rook the c6 which comes
with the idea that the knight here is
defended and also roofed h1 is now being
threatened
but now Grichuk has another winning idea
and it I'm not going to even ask you to
pause the video as it's it's the same
idea that we've already had in the video
it's just Bishop captures on f5 this was
a Grisha played he removed the defender
of the rook and you can't really capture
the bishop white of course saw this
white continue to attack with rook D to
G one Bishop back to g6 and now rook
captures on g6 his idea is okay I'm now
gonna eliminate your pieces and win the
Queen but black just has simply too much
material h capture send g6 and now rook
to h7 check forcing black to capture
with the Queen otherwise if the Queen
was anywhere else except on the H file
it would be made so Queen captures on h7
Knight captures King captures and now
you can't capture on c7 otherwise you
get Luke to see it and you lose the
Queen
so here it's two rooks and the bishop
against the Queen which is not not even
close for a for shoot to fight
blacks forces but okay Quinta D - he's
now ready to
here but now Bishop to b6 just defending
it with E 4 and now rook a to d8 of
course you cannot push a 5 now because
Bishop just captures the rook and King
occupy the same file so King to e3 but
now look after yet again putting both
all of the pieces into the game with f4
and now rook the e6 what idea so just
Bishop captures on f4 check picking up
the Queen so we have e 5 and now King to
g7 you still cannot capture here Queen
to b7 ready to capture on a6 and here
the grecian plays c5 allowing well
seemingly to capture on b6 but of course
you cannot capture right away white
first played d5 pushes pushes the rook
away rook to e7 and only now Queen
captures on b6 and it's a it is a pretty
tricky move for example if you brush up
the c7 just attacking the Queen then
Queen f6 check picks up the rook and if
you try to defend the rook Queen a trade
is mate the King has nowhere to go
so Grisha pure decided to give up the
bishop for two very stronger her pawns
in the center
he played bunch of characters on 85 with
F captures and now rook captures with
check King to f3 and here rook captures
and D if I was played and it was in this
position that young you should resign
the game as there is nothing more to do
here you will well if you go after the
a6 pawn for example black we'll just
play Ruby three check you don't want to
go up the board to allow some mating
patterns here so we're gonna go back but
now just to Rudy to check King III you
pick up this point and you create a past
C pawn and there's really not much what
you can do to stop at black will just
start pushing it if Queen c4 for example
preparing rook to c3 Queen to c3 to win
the rook here are you can just go rook
e8 check and once the King moves you're
gonna go f6 and you get this wonderful
position where white actually is in no
position to capture on c5 it's just
wonderful this is why I prolonged the
game to show you how you can win it
but if for example white captures here
then we get this excellent position
where where you are more than welcome to
pause the video and try to find the
winning idea for black here as it's just
very very educational and very nice so
once again for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent solver of puzzles and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
look the b3 you take away any squares
from the white king the pawns here do
the same the rock covers the e-file and
you are preparing g5 which will be
deadly
so whatever white place here let's say
you can try one check doesn't really
help you black will hide Queen to f7 you
go for example after drug but now you
get it g5 check King f5 King g4 is no
different now you look the e5 check you
force the King to capture here or or you
go back and then black will just
continue going after you if you capture
for example look if three check picks up
the Queen and now you have a nice
winning endgame where you are just upper
look so very exciting stuff
but after rook e capture son b5 should
resign the game and an excellent the
victory for Alexander Grisha with the
white with the black pieces and the next
game of course he gets the white pieces
so it is going to be easier for him and
much harder for you to catch up so yeah
that was my choice from round 3 if you
have a choice of your own use hashtag
suggestion and you know we're gonna
we're gonna check it out and if it's a
nice game of course we're gonna show it
if you're interested about dinkler and
versus Agha Reza fee Raja that game
ended in the draw it was a really
intense fight but I decide not sure
maybe tomorrow I'm gonna review it again
maybe I will show it it's hard to say
although I did just pull the result a
bit so but you guys don't mind about
that I know but yeah once again I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank James Dunn once again Jose Palacio
and luca petty for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos ER think of for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the World Cup
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and continuing what we
usually do here so thank you all I will
see Asian and heaven
rest of your day